this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you so much for the kind
introduction Julia it's really a
pleasure to be back here at Cornell this
is my third visit and enough to say it
gets better every time but it also gets
colder every time being in Georgia I
think the right caliber here but it's
really lovely I got to have a tour this
morning of the boys Thompson Institute
and enjoy the warmth of some of the
different plant growing areas so I'm
going to talk today about our work on
Medical ethnobotany as a discovery tool
for identification of novel chemical
scaffolds for the purpose of drug
discovery my main interest is an
anti-infective drug discovery but we
have also worked with collaborators and
looking for new scaffolds to treat
cancer and other viral targets other
than our bacterial and fungal work
you'll notice here our little logo if
anyone if there any chemists there and
this is illogic acid one of my first
major projects was on illogic acid
derivatives from from Rubis species so
that's how that came into being so I'm
going to talk about some of the
challenges that we have with antibiotic
resistance I'll go over the ethnobotany
is a key piece to the discovery toolkit
ethnobotany has kind of waxed and waned
over time and the 80s and 90s this was a
very respected
approach that was used widely also
supported through the National Cancer
Institute to to collect and and look for
new potential sources of compounds to
treat cancer among other targets but we
faced a downturn in interest and funding
in the 90s in the later 90s and even
from 2000 onwards and I feel like we're
finally getting back to a place where
people are starting to go back and
realize that we there's still a lot to
discover from the plant world in terms
of novel chemistry I'm going to talk
about how we're expanded this some
toolkit and then give you a few examples
of discoveries in this arena for we'll
talk about
the BlackBerry project our work with
chestnut pepper tree in st. John's wort
and for any of you that attended my
lecture last month of the tent gardens I
apologize for any slides that overlap
but I think what we're taking a deeper
dive into the science of this talk the
one of the major reasons that we're
working on this area of infectious
disease is because we're facing what is
going to be known as the post-antibiotic
era so we had the heyday of classic and
bio discovery
starting in the 40s into the 50s with a
lot of these metabolites from swell
microbes but we haven't had much
innovation in terms of antibiotic
discovery since then a lot of the new
antibiotics are actually just analogs of
existing structural classes that have
been released and so we're facing a
constant battle a game of leapfrog with
these bugs in our search for drugs that
will continue to work and so this is
sums it up I think quite well so
antibiotic resistance is not a new thing
that you know that has has reached the
limelight Alexander Fleming not long
after his received the Nobel Prize uhm
put this statement out of the
thoughtless person playing with
penicillin treatment is morally
responsible for the death of the man who
succumbs to the infection they knew from
the very beginning the antibiotic
resistance was going to be a major
problem if we did not take care of them
properly yesterday on on Twitter if any
of you are on Twitter I posted a
screenshot from another scientist that's
interested in antibiotic stewardship and
he had a screenshot from the website
Alibaba are you guys familiar with
Alibaba where that you could buy I mean
gram quantities of some of our major
antibiotics are used in human medicine
as well as some of these are in
veterinary medicine you know starting
from ten to thirty bucks online and that
is exceptionally disturbing that these
are so easily accessible through
international markets to get not only
being used recklessly and a lot of
veterinary practices in terms of growth
promoters for animals but also this kind
of ease of access through other avenues
as well
in 2016 the British government put
together a report this is known as the
O'Neil report based because it was
chaired by The Economist Jim O'Neill and
one of the key findings of this report
is that tackling animai microbial
resistance will require not only
stronger attention to stewardship but
also an adequate supply of new drugs to
beat resistance as it rises this is
troubling because we've seen a
continuous rise and rates of resistance
and our current estimates of the number
of deaths globally from antimicrobial
resistance are around 700,000 many think
that this is a very conservative
estimate it's anticipated to reach up to
10 million per year with current rates
of resistance by the year 2050 for the
first time ever the World Health
Organization released a target list of
pathogens to work on for human health
these you'll note or missing
tuberculosis tuberculosis is of course
still a very high priority for your
discovery they just kind of kept that in
a separate class but these are some of
the the key ones the ones in purple
we're working on in my lab as well as
the one in red I'm going to focus mainly
on our staff or cockle work because
that's where we have more data to
present but we are pursuing discovery
pathways for some of the escaped
pathogens in a row back Tracey
pseudomonas staff this new backdoor and
so on these gram-negative pathogens in
particular are very difficult to treat
because of issues with penetration of
the outer membrane and so we're also
working on trying to find natural
products from plants that may be on
their own aren't necessarily
antimicrobial but can actually
potentiate or sensitize the bugs to
existing lines of antibiotics so it's
kind of rude that resistance modifying
agents that's one of our main approaches
that we're taking with these gram
negatives right now so the other
troubling aspect to this whole crisis is
that
well we've seen rising rates of
resistance
the same time we've faced a big
discovery void starting in the 1990s we
don't have any new registered classes of
antibiotics since the late 1980s and
anytime you've seen the news these new
antibiotics again they're not really new
new they're based on the same scaffolds
just slightly modified so resistance is
a constant problem it might work for a
few years and then again we have
resistance to that class again
now this also correspond with a shift in
the way that we look for our antibiotics
and we moved more further away from
natural products they were still doing
some work with soil microbes and that
kind of discovery for natural products
but not so heavily emphasized on plants
and more focused on products of
combinatorial chemistry the idea during
this period was if we can build large
enough libraries of hundreds of
thousands of compounds and screen them
with our new you know high-throughput
robotics programs that surely something
would hit and does anybody know how many
antibiotics came out of that initiative
that was Multi multi millions of dollars
zero nothing and a consequence of that
is while we have this emphasis more
towards synthetic approaches which you
know I love synthetic chemists they are
my friends so don't take this as an
affront if your synthetic chemists but
one of the one of the the dire
consequences of this is we saw a drop in
training of people that have that
natural products expertise and that are
taking this approach of looking to
different sources of nature for these
new products the other problem was that
we kept rediscovering a lot of the same
compounds from these different soil
microbes so here are some the latest
representatives of the novel anti
bacterial classes that were released
more recently one of these as recently
as 2007 but again these were discovered
in the 1950s so we need to do better at
discovery of new classes people are
looking to a number of different natural
sources I'm still screening the soil and
there's some innovative new techniques
that have emerged where there are new
types of growth chambers these ID chip
devices that can be used to grow micro
in their native soil environment there
are folks that are working on marine
organisms they're going to remote areas
of the planet looking at extreme
ecosystems trying to identify perhaps
other microbes in the marine environment
or other larger organisms Andry
environment as sources of these
compounds some are focusing on into
fights or fungi that live within plants
some are focusing on genome mining going
back to those original sources of
antibiotics some on animal proteins
right so Halle Gators Komodo dragons
these have been kind of some of the
interesting things that have popped out
in the news and then plants and fungi
are also on the area where we're
particularly focused on now it should
come as no surprise especially to this
audience that plants would be irrational
a reasonable place to look for new
compounds we have a long history of
successful drug discovery from plants
and in fact many of the drugs that are
in the the World Health Organization's
list of essential medicines were
originally derived from plants and have
since since then we now synthesize or or
create these compounds through other
mechanisms but I think there's a lot to
be discovered here we also know that
there are around 28,000 medicinal plants
have been documented on earth this is
from the recent Q report in current
estimates for total species is somewhere
around four hundred and four hundred
fifty thousand species of plants known
on earth but twenty-eight thousand of
those have been documented for medicinal
use there are no formal numbers on how
many plants have actually been
thoroughly investigated for their
potential bio activity but as far as the
anti-infective field goes I would say
it's in the very low hundreds of ones
that have been really looked at from a
robust biological or chemical angle so
why do plants make these compounds is
all about creation of secondary
metabolites different tissues will
engage a different biosynthetic pathways
to create plants for the defense against
microbial invasion or infection now
something that's interests
is that perhaps we know that with fungi
they can create compounds that actually
kill other organisms plants can as well
but what we're finding in my work is
that the signaling pathways between
plant and and and pathogen there might
be a more intricate or interesting
communication system there where perhaps
they're not just killing these bugs that
are actually preventing their own or
interfering with microbial signaling
systems and that's where we get into
quorum sensing interference which is
what I'll talk about in a bit other
secondary metabolites are at least to
attract pollinators and seed dispersers
they're at least to prevent other
species from germinating within their
within their kind of grow zone and then
of course you have secondary metabolites
that can be up regulated prevent over
foraging by animals now the other thing
that I think was really interesting is
in 2015 more attention also got placed
on the role of plants entry infectious
disease with dr. u2's received the Nobel
Prize for her discovery of artemisinin
and what I love about this story is that
it not only incorporated it was not only
a story about successful natural
products work but it's also a story
about you the use of ethnobotanical
tools in that discovery process so they
had yield problems when they're working
with Artemisia they had yield problems
with their active compounds and she
actually went back to this five century
old text and looked up the traditional
way that this was prepared to treat
febrile illness and in fact it was not
created during using standard lab
mechanisms of an organic extraction or
perhaps a hot aqueous extraction instead
it was you know wrung out in in
room-temperature water
and indeed they did get higher yields of
their active agent that way
so the other thing that's interesting i
think from the artemisinin story is that
now we have widespread Artemis and
resistance of course because we isolated
that one single compound from the plant
and used it broadly I think that there's
a lot of lessons to be learned from this
and that when you look at some of these
other studies that have actually tried
whole plant therapy you get some
restoration of activity against the
malaria parasite so there may be a role
for all these other structurally similar
derivatives that are kicked off through
that biosynthetic pathway that may be
together in unison they can help beat
resistance and that's an area that we're
very interested in when it comes to our
anti effective drugs are we actually
doing a disservice by isolating only
trying to develop single molecules would
be better in some cases actually work on
development of refined enriched extracts
that are rich in these molecules and
some of which might have actually
slightly less activity but as a whole
work better together and I'll give you
an example of that with our only
blackberry work so our core research
approach is we have kind of four angles
to the lab we do field work this summer
I was working in the Mediterranean we've
done a lot of field work also in Albania
and in Kosovo and the Balkans we also
collect in the southeast us so we have
plants that come from Florida and also
from Georgia and for those us
collections were relying primarily on
historic records of Native American
medicine medical uses of these plants
all of our specimens are deposited in
our barium where you know you have
taxonomic verification that what we
field ID'd is correct and those are
stored there we also have a
phytochemistry lab which is where we
extract the compounds and to start
creating our library and then we have
microbiology and cell culture so all
this is kind of run under the umbrella
of my research group so in taking the
epidermis hampel approach to drug
discovery again we're starting with all
biological diversity but we're using
this important lens of ethnobotany
to narrow down the field even beyond
these twenty eight thousand known
medicinal plants focusing primarily on
plants that are used to treat infectious
and inflammatory disease I'm especially
interested in skin disease and in
topical applications of plants because
from a from a chemistry perspective it's
a lot easier to work with those because
you don't have to worry as much about
compound degradation as you would with
therapies they're taken internally or
orally
these are extracted and we work up
standard mass spec and NMR on these
compounds the other thing that's
interesting I think about or unique
about our collection is that we focus
again in the Mediterranean Basin the
National Cancer Institute's large global
collections they did on the plants and
also marine sources did not include
Europe or the Mediterranean and so I
could clearly say that of all the
collections are out there for natural
products I think we have some unique
species or an unique collection of
species in this group in the approach
we're using tools from anthropology and
tools from ethnobotany we're actively
interviewing people about how they're
using plants the places that we work are
very remote and oftentimes these people
are reliant on knowledge of which plants
to collect in the wild for both food and
medicine for example some of our work in
the Balkans they are isolated for about
six months of the year with heavy snows
so they have to actually grow or collect
a lot all their food to last throughout
the winter they and then also ferment a
lot of these foods through lactic acid
fermentation for long-term storage and
potatoes are their major crop here we
are in the participant observation of
helping to plant potatoes with some of
these ladies we're also looking to old
text as well this is an example of a
text from the 16th 16th century that
included notes from a Dutch explorer
traveling in South America and this is
the Brazilian pepper tree it's one of
the plants that we've been working on so
there are when people ask me about how
do I pick my field site everyone assumes
for some reason I just like to go to
Italy for the wine which is you know
okay it's not bad and it's a beautiful
place to work but there is a scientific
rationale behind you know why we're
working the Mediterranean it is one of
the global hot spots for biodiversity we
have we have over 25,000 plants that are
native to the Mediterranean Basin but
13,000 of those are endemic so there's
again a nice opportunity for collecting
a wide variety of biological diversity
which also then of course
corresponds to chemical diversity and
our drug discovery initiatives what else
is interesting is that you know when you
look at how people use plants in these
areas you have a relatively small
geographic region but you have multiple
languages that are spoken you have
different cultures different religions
and in fact we've found that even people
that share the same ecosystem this is
from our paper and in nature plants we
found that even people that share the
same ecosystem if they're from a
different culture that have different
linguistic customs and different customs
for their daily life they actually use
those natural resources in very
different ways and that's especially
relevant to how they use some of these
medicinal plants for day-to-day medical
care so to undertake this research we go
through layers of prior informed consent
with both village leaders and also
individuals we follow codes of ethics
for this kind of work where you're again
gathering information from people in how
they use plants and we also engage in
access and benefit sharing this our work
may or may not someday lead to great
outcomes in terms of translational
outcomes for medicine with lots of money
that's always the hope right that you
can find a drug that gets developed but
the reality is that most of these
probably won't that won't occur so we
really take a big emphasis on engaging
in access and benefit sharing from the
very GetGo so some of the things that we
get back to communities are languages or
books in the local language we run
workshops we also engage in a lot of
different exchange programs with the
students so in the field we're
collecting these plants their field
dried and then shipped back to the lab
or their ground up with a mill and then
extracted and following various
procedures they might be extracted
through organic extractions or boiling
or in some cases we also try and follow
the traditional means of extraction as
well these are then the solvents then
removed then we're working with these
crude extracts in our initial screens so
each extract from different plant
tissues may contain from several hundred
to up to a thousand different small
molecules so our current library is now
we have over 1200 extracts from plants
and fungi these also we have a pre
fractionated library on top of that on a
large chunk of these and I think what's
nice is that these are also highly
biologically diverse we have fifty fifty
one orders over four hundred species and
they cover I think a good spectrum of
plant diversity which gives us a unique
chance to then screen you know not just
1200 compounds we're probably actually
screening more in you know the scale of
a millions of compounds because each of
these is so diverse and complex so in
when we get to the microbiology lab some
of the classic ways that people have
looked at the anti bacterial potential
of medicinal plants has been following
our standard in the Box thought line we
need things that kill or inhibit the
growth of bacteria and across the board
the literature that's what you're going
to find if you look for antibacterial
activity of who to some plants you're
gonna see people that run these
microtiter broth assays which is
basically you have the bacteria growing
and culture and you look at optical
density to see if your compounds block
their growth or kill them you also might
see a lot of these distribution assays
where you basically have an auger dish
with compound on a disc or compound in
and well or extract in a while and you
look for zones of inhibition this is
this is the standard of where a lot of
work is done we also do this but I think
what is important as we go a step beyond
because I think a lot of the a lot of
the the rationale for why these plants
are being used in traditional medicine
is actually being missed this way it's
very easy to dismiss a traditional
medicine if you say oh this is used for
a skin infection but it doesn't kill any
of the bacteria that we know of that
cause skin infections so this is just an
old wives tale doesn't work it's junk
and I think that's been the perspective
a lot of scientists have taken in in in
this process in the past and so we're
really trying to make a push to
encourage people to think about other
potential mechanisms other pathways
where these compounds might actually be
working
so we're looking at pathways that are
involved in recalcitrants of infections
were long and during chronic kind of
wound infections
that's where biofilm comes into play
we're looking at compounds that inhibit
quorum sensing or bacterial
communication this is very important for
virulence factor production that's
responsible for tissue damage and we're
also looking for resistance modification
can these actually potentiate recents at
high as other classic and bacterials and
lastly there's also the host directed
impact and this is an area that we
haven't been working but I'm hoping to
find a strong immunologist collaborator
in the future to take on this angle
because we've been so focused on how
does it interact with the bug we have we
don't often think about how does it
actually interact with the host which
might provide some interesting insight
for medicine so in our approach for lead
identification we're starting with field
work or literature review we collect the
plan so we go through taxonomic
identification we're collecting plant
DNA to have these DNA bar-coded and
enter it into international databases we
are processing the materials in the
field and then going through this
process of bioassay guided fractionation
so at each step it's you have something
that's incredibly complex we get a hit
we separate using criminal matter
graphic techniques then go back retest
and keep trying to refine and refine it
I just had another me about our chestnut
project where we were getting so close
to identifying the active compounds and
I was very disappointed to find that
that one peak that we found and isolated
in a large quantity on our prep LC
actually turned out to be 5 compounds
still and it's like every time you get
closer and closer it's just like the set
of Russian dolls there's something else
there right but that's kind of also the
exciting part about this it's not an
easy approach but there's a lot there to
be discovered following bio asagaya
fractionation we also go to animal
studies we use a lot of mouse models we
can also use um Gloria Mellon ella
models which are basically these insect
models that you can use for looking at
pathogenesis for some of these packages
so I'm in a focus today on staph aureus
because we have a couple of examples of
different plants that interact with this
particular pathogen to give you some
background Staphylococcus aureus is in
the firm acute division of microbes it's
a leading cause of bacteremia and sepsis
brain abscess medical implanted device
infections we have new drugs again new
drugs that have been put out they're not
really new and if you talk to an
infectious disease doctor they don't
always work they work beautifully in a
test tube but when you're dealing with a
live patient these are incredibly
difficult infections in some cases to
treat especially for medical medical
device infections one thing of interest
is one in three of you actually carry
staph aureus and you're in your in your
nose and you're an Aries doesn't mean
that you're going to become sick from
this but it could lead to potential for
transmission to other people that are
perhaps more immune compromised there
are two different types of staph that
play an important role in health one is
known as H a and where s a or
healthcare-associated mr sa or that
stands for methicillin-resistant
Staphylococcus aureus this is a
resistant lineage that is associated
with infections of people that are
already sick in the hospital are there
for surgery or you know have some sort
of immune compromised State then there
is community associated M RSA which is a
new lineage that emerged in the past 15
to 20 years that allows this bug to
actually get into very healthy
individuals and I'll talk more about
that and how some these plant compounds
me play a role in that so let's start
with biofilm and this idea of intrinsic
resistance so biofilms can be either you
know microbial or polymicrobial these
occur in nature if you've ever looked at
a slimy rock in a stream that's the
slime is from a microbial biofilm these
are advantageous to microbes because it
provides them a safe haven and a place
where they can kind of work
cooperatively with each other so it
starts with initial adhesion to a
surface they grow into these mushroom
like
structures and through these channels
that you can see here that's where they
exchange genetic information so you have
much higher rates of genetic exchange in
these communities they also release
their waste products through those
channels and also take up nutrients
what's bad about the biofilm in terms of
the human host is that these are
incredibly difficult to clear once
they're in that Grove state they also in
to enter into slower metabolic rate so
they grow slower antibiotics work on
rapidly dividing cells it's also more
difficult for the antibiotics actually
penetrate that polysaccharide matrix
it's also difficult for your immune
system to clear that matrix as well so
let's go back to Italy this is from some
of my work I started off doing as a
graduate student documenting how people
in these rural villages for treating
skin and soft-tissue infections so I got
to go around and ask hundreds of people
questions about what did they put on
their skin for postulant using wounds I
mean it's a great conversation starter
right it's like so you remember that
time you have that nasty abscess with
all that stuff coming out what did you
do for that and I got a lot of really
interesting responses everything from
using slug slime to you know lots of
different plants and even some different
industrial chemicals used in agriculture
I was like that sounds that could be
painful but this is one of those that
popped up and what was interesting is
that the they would actually take the
leaves and layer it with some aged pork
fat on the skin and they were also using
the roots to treat hair loss and this is
basically a large briar patch so it's
not easy to go in and collect they also
use the fruits and as edible for
marmalades
so we had there were over 116 different
remedies related to skin and soft-tissue
infections that we documented and this
is one that we collected now when I
looked at this in our in our models for
inhibition of growth does not inhibit
growth so again most people stopped at
that point when it came to evaluation of
antimicrobials but we went an additional
step and ask the question okay what
other potential processes does this
inter interact
so we use this assay it's a very simple
crystal violet assay where basically you
grow your organisms in your 96-well
plate when they form a biofilm under
certain media conditions basically
they'll form a layer at the bottom of
the well other organisms will form
they'll adhere to the kind of where that
air liquid interfaces but the staff
forms at the bottom and kind of around
the sides and so the question is if we
add these extracts to the wells as
they're trying to form the biofilm can
it stop them from forming and indeed we
found that it did and this is an image
from a confocal laser-scanning
microscopy some study where we have two
different strains of staph this is a
hospital strain taken from the
osteomyelitis patient so it's a bone
infection and this is a strain of one of
those more aggressive community acquired
infections found in blood streams of
healthy healthy individuals this is a
mutant that is basically does not form a
biofilm so when you add this this is at
different concentrations 220 df2 is our
refined version of the extract it's
enriched for content of ellagic acid
glycosides and we'll get to why that's
important in a moment but you can see
with dose-response and 100 micrograms
per mil there's basically no adhesion
this is a glass slide green shows growth
or live cells red as dead cells and a
healthy biofilm is composed of live and
dead cells but they're just not adhering
and here you have it 50 micrograms there
are some that are adhering but not many
and at 12 micrograms you can see that
some of them are a hearing but if you
look here this is a this is a way of
looking at it from the side view so you
can see the height of the towers you can
envision again those mushroom shaped
towers what happens is in the presence
of the drug they form these very tall
unstable towers so if you think about it
from the perspective of architecture if
you build a building too tall what
happens to it right so it's it's not as
fit of a structure and so our next
question is you know in the presence of
these compounds can we actually remove
an established biofilm that's the golden
question right if you have an implanted
device let's say you have your need
placement gets infected currently the
way that it's treated in the hospital is
the physicians going to put you under
high doses of antibiotics they're going
to go in and drain the pus because it's
red and large inflamed and oozy and pus
infection they're going to scrape it out
or debride it and then they have to
remove the device put in a temporary
device that's embedded with antibiotics
that will leach antibiotics into the
area for a while put you back on IV
antibiotics then after it looks like
you're healed they'll come back in take
the temporary device out put in a longer
term device now for some of these
procedures the recurrence rate of
infection is up to 40% those are not
good odds that's our current standard of
therapy so if we had ways to actually
prevent that biofilm from attaching in
the first place or actually treating a
patient that has this kind of infection
was something that eradicate sore
removes that biofilm with that out
actually having to remove the whole
device that's embedded in your bone that
would be great so that's the question we
asked here can we take these plant
compounds and remove that goopy biofilm
community from a device so this is just
a piece of IV catheter so the same kind
of IVs that go into your arm when you're
in the hospital we took one centimeter
segments grew the biofilm on it and then
treated it through a series of days in
different media continued either just
growth media the biofilm inhibitor alone
antibiotic alone or biofilm hitter plus
antibiotic now we are disappointed to
find that then blue is the biofilm
control and this is the biofilm
inhibitor and orange that we had no drop
and adhered cells when treating with
just the biofilm inhibitor right so it
wasn't able to remove the established
biofilm but if you look at the
antibiotic this is ten times the typical
dose of daptomycin it's ten times the
breakpoint m.i.c you only had a very
small this is not even quite 2 log drop
in adherent cells but what got us
excited is that when you combined the
inhibitor plus thing about it we saw a
large 5 log drop in tiered cells and
this is after seven days of treatment we
didn't completely clear the biofilm
but this gives you a sense of how
difficult these are
to treat right this is why do we have to
actually remove the device but this is
bringing a steps closer to thinking
about different ways to treat these
kinds of infections now within this
mixture this is a refined mixture we
knew that we had a logic acid in a bunch
of these glycosidic forms of it but we
found that each time that we try to
separate the extract past that point of
220 f2 we started losing activity and so
we recombined it in multiple different
ways we took our fractions and we
combined fraction 1 and 10 and 8 and 10
and all them together in all these
different myriad ways and the only way
we were able to restore the total
activity of 220 df2 is if we actually
put the entire thing back together of
220 f2 so this was a problem and for
those of you that do any natural
products isolation you know that I slay
enough of each individual compound from
the extract can be very time consuming
and difficult so I went down the hill to
a chemistry this is dr. Emily whiner and
I said you know can you just make these
for me because I don't know how to do
this and she said okay I didn't realize
at the time I was giving her a brick
right because ellagic acid has serious
solubility issues but she was able to do
this and she actually generated a number
of different glycosidic forms of the
ellagic acid and what we found from this
study was that the type of sugar did
matter we saw some enhanced um activity
with single compounds that had certain
kinds of sugars but what we found
overall again is that that enriched
botanical fraction that had a
composition of many different logic acid
glycosides was still the most active so
this was I think interesting and goes
back against this idea that I brought up
before the artemisinin is is actually
this enriched composition better than
going to a single drug in some cases we
also wanted to look and see what other
organisms does this work again so I did
this in collaboration with dr. Jorge
Vidale who's at Emory School of Public
Health and he's a he's an expert in
streptococcus pneumoniae and what we
found was strep pneumonia was very
interesting is that in this case 220 f2
actually did kill strep pneumonia and it
also broke up established biofilm so
that was really exciting that here
it actually behaves differently it's
another gram-positive caucus but it
behaves very differently than it does
with staph aureus so there's some
potential here also for other avenues of
development for strep pneumoniae
infections now let's get back to
community associated MRA and this is
where my quorum sensing work I think
really comes into play so this is an
epidemic
I mentioned that really shocked the
medical community and the public health
officials because traditionally again
staff was something that affected sick
people or people had implant devices
then all of a sudden you started seeing
football players a military personnel
I'm talking about nineteen year old men
and the prime of health very fit very
you know immune stable that we're coming
down with these really severe infections
healthy one day and at death's door in a
few days I mean really serious kinds of
infections they often we present as a
skin infection in the ER in fact so
staph skin infections are very common in
the ER view they're often confused by
people as being spider bites you ever
see this kind of circular infection that
has a red hole in the middle that's not
a spider bite it's often it's staph
aureus kind of skin infection and in
most cases and that hole is caused by
these toxins that staph produces that
can cause this necrotic lesion so what
they found is you had this this this
severe sorts of infections we're
starting off and with the skin and then
moving systemically and infecting people
so what they did is they took these
strains here's a classic study where
they tried to replicate what they were
seeing in the clinic you had the
hospital strain if you injected that
into the bloodstream of the mouse the
mouse survived Matt mice are actually
quite good at fighting off staff if you
took one of these new community
associated strains you started to see
deaths in mice within a very short
amount of time so there is something
different that these bugs were doing
again this is not about drug resistance
this is about virulence staph exotoxins
which are part of that virulence package
are associated with a number of
different diseases
one of the classic ones is toxic shock
syndrome this was a big problem in a
period where you had women using super
absorbent tampons those were taken off
the market for the long-term use because
of this association you have scalded
skin syndrome and units this actually is
caused by exfoliated toxins that makes
the baby's skin fall off extremely
dangerous because of course you're
removing that important immune barrier
and can be opened up for additional
secondary infections and then the hall
markers abscesses necrosis and sepsis
and what's great about this from a
botany perspective again is that people
who describe this chimi
they can tell me I saw this on my skin
it was really gross it felt like this or
if it's a rash it spread it had fluid
the fluid was clear the fluid was was
postulant you can get a lot of
information from from visual
confirmation by people using plants for
these kinds of indications now what
makes this kind of staff so potent is
that it has this increased capacity to
release toxins and they actually use
this they use this capacity to recruit
neutrophils and basically are gobbled up
by the neutrophil once they're inside
they release a burst of toxin and
actually actively attack your immune
system this is what makes them able to
get into the bloodstream from these skin
infections and spread throughout the
body and a much more effective way than
the other classic hospital-associated
once did so when I was in doing my PhD
work there was a lot of talk by folks at
NIH like Michael Otto had a lot of
really interesting papers that were more
opinion papers and kind of
forward-thinking papers what if we could
come up with drugs to target this system
of communication that controls virulence
and it was always the big what-if in
their appeal they were working on some
peptide signaling agents inhibitors and
I at the time of course was working on
these postulant wounds and I'm thinking
well maybe this is a way that could
explain how some of these work in the
clinic and so I end up with dr. poore as
well who's an expert in the accessory
gene regulator system and staff and he
was able to build a number of tools that
we use to assess these the
these compounds so the idea here is to
use a quorum quenching approach we're
not actually killing the organism but
limiting its ability to communicate
either through releasing signals or
receiving signals this is what the
system looks like so you have a constant
release of these Auto inducing peptides
into the cells extracellular environment
and these are recognized here by a GRC
this triggers a phosphorylation event
and then downstream you have a
production of a number of different
toxins including super antigen Saito
license things that can burst open
immune cells red blood cells degrade
your tissue and also help get past that
skin barrier this is really important
for the skin barrier function so in
dermatology we're always concerned with
skin barrier function if you lose that
that that shield of your skin if your
skin barrier is degraded in any way it
opens you up for invasion by not only
staff but other pathogens are in the
environment it also opens you up to more
contact with allergens in the
environment so this is relevant for
diseases also like eczema I don't know
if any of you are familiar with eczema
about 20% of kids in the US and other
developed countries deal with eczema or
atopic dermatitis and staff is heavily
involved in that disease as well because
of its role in impacting skin barrier
function and causing itch through mast
cell degranulation and histamine release
so let's go back to Italy again here's
another case where we dog-human that the
use of chestnut this is just your
standard
castaigne sativa standard chestnut grown
across Europe for its fruits for its
edible fruits and we had documentation
of local people using the leaves of
chestnut as an anti-inflammatory agent
for inflammatory skin disease much like
what you would see in a classic eczema
patient and so again we look at this
plant found it did not inhibit the
growth of bacteria it doesn't really do
much on biofilm but it does inhibit this
signaling system and staph aureus
so by taking these we basically in some
of these sites we grew the bacteria and
the presence of the plant extract and
then looked at the damage that the cells
supernatant this is basically the waste
products of the bacteria we put onto
human cells
so the waste product would normally
contain a lot of these toxins that are
excreted from the cell so if you put
that on to a cell line you're going to
see all of your cells are just going to
die and we're working with human skin
cells so those skin cells die and the
ones that were pre treated though with
our extract we found that they were
protected because there's no toxin in
that supernatant
right because you're turning off their
ability to release toxin so we wanted to
see how this works in an animal so in
this model you have this is a little
mouse sorry for you that get disturbed
by animal images but here's a little
mouse we take one of those nasty
community associate mrs a strains that
affects healthy people inject it into
the skin dermis so it's an intradermal
intradermal injection and you can see
that after two days this big necrotic
lesions occurs so by release of toxins
the staff is degrading the skin okay now
we tried to then at the same time as we
give the bacteria we also give them a
small dose of the chestnut extract this
is a refined extract again of Earth
scene and all you mean derivatives okay
and if five micrograms you see a small
much smaller lesion but it still forms
and at 50 micrograms
there's no lesion formation but you can
see this little pocket right remember
this is not an antibiotic it's not
actually killing the bugs the bugs are
still there but it's you've just
completely disarmed them so it's a
different way of thinking about how do
you fight your enemy I'm a big fan of
Sun Tzu's Art of War right I think we
did think more about that when we think
about how to better manage infectious
disease you know can you disarm your
enemy by by other means so the bacteria
is still there it just can't cause any
damage and an immune competent organism
you can then clear out that infection
right so let's go forward to another
story this is a Brazilian pepper tree
this is our Maurice
publication and in Brazilian pepper tree
this is a plant that is shyest Herman
thief olya is in the antic RDA see so
this is relative of mango and poison ivy
very important in traditional medicine
in South America especially in Brazilian
medicine and there's been a lot of
records of many different ways it was
used and a lot of different cases of
infectious disease on the fruits who are
understudied though I found in the
literature and so we decided to go and
collect some now luckily I'm from this
part of Florida you can see why I'm not
used to cold I'm from here this is by my
County I took some students down and we
went collected more of of the the fruits
and leaves and different tissues at the
plant because it's a it's an invasive
species in Florida it's a noxious weed
there are actually big programs that are
geared towards removal of this plant so
hated plant which is kind of kind of an
underdog story for me so in the in the
chemistry lab we take that extract we
had a basic methanol at crude extract we
then undergo liquid liquid partitioning
these are basically two standard ways of
separating compounds based on polarity
then go to flash chromatography and we
can go on to prep or semi prep and so on
to isolate compounds so you can see at
each stage here's the crude extract as
we enrich it or as we work on those more
active parts you can see and you have
greater concentration of these active
compounds so in our assays I want to
just show you a few examples we have a
reporter system there are four types of
signaling systems and staff of four
different peptides of that AG are
releases so we have reporters for each
of those we wanted to control closely
for growth so we found it's not
inhibiting growth any of these reporters
but it is blocking their ability to
signal or communicate between each other
again in our mouse model we saw that you
have your lesion with at this case with
50 microgram injection not as effective
as a chestnut but again you see the same
kind of activity of blocking that
necrotic pathway we also for the first
time showed this in the live model using
a fluorescent reporter strains in the
live mouse that we are in the mouse
in this specific gene system to help
prevent necrotic Legion formation now
for those of you this is this is what
we're working with this is a clean clean
version of the extract plant extracts
are of course incredibly chemically
complex and we're now focused on trying
to isolate these individually through
prep chromatography to then do more work
to understand which of these compounds
are involved and again thinking about
this question of do they work better
together one of my main concerns if you
go back to these four different AGR
signaling peptides is you know it might
it might be that the mixture works
better overall because it's very
difficult you're not going to have a
position AGR type your infection they're
going to say is it staph or not I'm not
going to go beyond that so I think it
could be advantageous to have a mixture
that targets all four types I think what
else was interesting is that we showed
that this does not inhibit growth of
your skin commensals right so you one of
the challenges in antibiotic development
is that while we're hitting these nasty
bugs the same time we're also killing
all of your commensal organisms this is
why we have big issues with c diff
infections and the gut when you clear
out your healthy commensal system so
we've found in skin organisms at least
with the exception of acne this does not
inhibit growth some of the different
targets we're working on are again
looking at two atopic dermatitis
acute bacterial and skin and soft-tissue
infections and I'm actually thinking
more broadly now also towards veterinary
medicine because atopic infections and
dogs is actually also quite common so
we're thinking about a doggy cream
formulation for this as well as maybe
the first place to start because the
hurdles to getting this into a clinical
study in dogs are much lower than going
to humans as a first strain place I want
to talk just briefly about this one last
plant of st. John's wort you've all
probably heard of this it's Hypericum
for freedom it's used in the Balkans as
a interesting way they actually create a
Sun oil infusion of the flowering aerial
parts so when you go to your standard
health
store you don't find that kind of
formulation you see they have organic
extracts they're sold either in liquid
or tablet form and again mainly used for
mental health rather than infectious
disease but what we document in our
studies over and over in the Balkans is
that this particular formulation it's
locally known as Pantheon is incredibly
important for the treatment management
of skin disease and one of my things I
was worried about is that the presence
of hypericin
in the dietary supplement tablets can
actually cause a disease called high
parasitism which is a photoreactive skin
disease basically you're more
susceptible to getting sunburned easily
when you have this in your diet so my
question is here we have these people
that are rubbing this all over their
skin all the time and yet there were no
reports of high parasitism there were no
reports of skin photo reactivity and so
my question was is it because their
formulae in a different way that they
actually are at lower risk now the major
a bacterial compound here is hypericin
and hyperforin also has some
antibacterial activity this is the
compound that causes that photo reactive
side effect so this was actually a study
done by one of my undergraduates I
really love working with undergrads in a
lab I try and get students when they
start at sophomores and they work with
me all the way through senior year so
he's a co first author on this paper and
what he did is he went and collect gots
different tablets from supplement stores
and then also worked with the plant
materials that we collected in the
Balkans as well as the traditional
formulation of this prepared in olive
oil or in sunflower oil and what we
found is that when you look at growth
inhibition the tablets and supplements
and even the aqueous of methanol
extracts were potently antibacterial
that they also had very high levels of
hypericin whereas the oils really didn't
have much antibacterial activity so
again traditional medicine but is not
killing staph or any of these skin
bacteria that caused this disease so
then we looked at quorum sensing we saw
it did have some moderate quorum
quenching activity in the oils so that
might be one potential explanation for
why this works
and when we looked at the chromatograms
of through mass spec evaluating each of
these formulations what we found across
the board again is that the oils lacked
the presence of of hypericin so these
are dead lacking the toxic compound and
not eliciting a standard antibacterial
activity but have some mild aunt a
quorum sensing activity as well as some
mild anti biofilm activity i didn't show
that data so i'm going to wrap up here
and just say that you know i think that
one of the things that we can do in the
plant science is is to think more
broadly also concerning again this idea
of signaling in the in the environment
plants are signaling with organisms in
their environment for their own survival
in some cases we also have crossover
with targets into human pathogens i
think this is a an interesting area to
work and i think again that traditional
medicine can help us to focus in on
those species that are most likely to
have some kind of interference with with
the human pathogens our work we also i
didn't get a chance to talk about the
other targets we also have some really
cool projects ongoing right now with
collaborators on zika virus we found a
really potent inhibitor of replication
for zika we're also working on some of
these superbugs fungus infections like
canada ours from some of our plants so
these are not yet published but will be
hopefully soon and i just want to wrap
up with you know can we look beyond
these old paradigms of kill kill kill i
think that as we come to the end of the
antibiotic era we have to think about
paradigm shifts in medicine and a role
that some of these different again
signaling inhibitors might play in
managing disease in the future so these
are where i'll end and thank you and how
far we've got for questions
[Applause]
Sarris probably a lot more microbiology
than you guys were hoping for in a plant
like Kim in the bacterias all day but
just quenching the virus and do you
think that's I think I think that's
exactly right I mean there's that's the
other kind of thing that everyone wants
is the resistance proof drug now I think
it depends on whether or not you have
additional selective pressures at play
perhaps resistance could evolve I think
it's less likely than the direct
selective pressures that we have with
classic antibiotics so we've actually
done a lot of resistant studies with
these drugs we've done a lot of cereal
packaging basically growing these in the
presence of of the warm winters over
generations and have not found any drop
in their ability to quench signaling now
that was in the absence of an of an
additional selective pressure so what
would be optimal is if we could do this
in an animal model we've been thinking
about ways to do this perhaps in
gallery' ml NL and the insect model so
we could then pass it through
generations of insects and that's
something that we have on them we have
on the horizon you see or have you tried
to see gistic effects of your
combination of plants so making a
formula different plants we have not you
know something a film that effect quorum
sensing and see if we haven't done that
yet we've focused mainly on combinations
with existing antibiotics but that could
be an interesting thing to do I guess
but the reason I haven't really done it
is more from a translational perspective
it's already really difficult to get an
IND going on these when you have you
know through the botanical drug pathway
for these I think if I'm combining
different extracts that's not
permissible under that pathway but from
a kind of an inquiry standpoint that
could be interesting I mean I think that
traditional Chinese medicine is
incredibly complex and you can spend a
lifetime studying it in fact people do
it's um
I think there are a lot of interesting
bioactive ingredients used in
traditional Chinese medicine but to
study it with the tools that we have
today you would need to really look at
perhaps single plant tissues to start
off with but in the future as we
advanced kind of these different
metabolomics approaches perhaps there
are better ways to study the complex
mixtures one of the problems with with
with some of these forms of medicine is
you know or if you're able to actually
collect the fresh plant as a botanist I
always like emphasize actual
identification of the species and so if
you go into a traditional Chinese
medicine shop there are lots of dried
bits of plants and roots and leaves and
like well it's difficult to ensure that
you have the correct species that you're
working on yeah but I think it's a
fascinating area I'm like I already deal
in so much complexity though the idea of
working on ingredients that involve you
know ingredients from five different
species and different tissues into one
formulation is just beyond my capacity
to deal with right now
okay thank you so much this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu